now back inside the State Capitol in
Austin with George krile and former
representative Charlie Wilson on
Charlie's War this is just under an hour
good afternoon it's good to see all of
you here in the Senate chamber this
historic room and it's old home to one
of our panelists what we're here today
to discuss is the book called charlie
wilson's war by george krile this is the
hitherto unknown story of how the United
States was involved in the war in
Afghanistan on the side of the jaw
Hadean that helped drive the Russians
out and in its own way bringing into the
Cold War it is a marvelous story it is a
virtually unknown story it's a very
dramatically told story in this book the
author who was here to my right is
George cryo he is a producer for 60
minutes for 60 minutes - and he took
time off to write this book to my left
is a congressman Charles Wilson now
retired from the Congress who prior to
being a congressman was a state senator
in this very chamber and he really did
some amazing things some of which he is
happy to have chronicled and some of
which perhaps not so happy that will be
one of the questions we'd love to hear
today but we're we're delighted to have
them and to have all of you I'm going to
begin with let the panelists do the
talking in just a minute but as the
gallery files in I want to just again
repeat that we would like to have all
questions asked at the back microphone
here that's the back of the Senate
chamber and if you will when you're
ready to and we'll probably be taking
questions in about 30 minutes and then
you can line up at the start lining up
and people in the gallery we invite you
please to come down and ask questions
with that I would
would like to turn it over to George
krile the author and he can tell us a
little bit of how this project resulted
in this terrific book George I think I'm
a bit like most Americans which is I
would like to feel good and proud about
what our country is doing abroad when it
enters into an area of national security
concerns and I certainly was part of a
generation which so many of us were
influenced by when John Kennedy gave his
inaugural address and created that sense
of mission and after that I was also
part of a generation which got struck by
the Vietnam and came to be concerned for
so many years about what we were doing
and I think I was probably yearning
always for a moment where you could go
back to that sense of mission where you
felt you were on the right side and we
were doing things in the world that made
a difference that could make you proud
and that we're useful and I can tell you
that of all people in this world that I
might have expected to find as the as
the charger on a on a white horse doing
good the last the very last person I
would have imagined in that role would
be the right honourable Charles Wilson
who used to sit in this chamber and
delighted most everybody in this city
and certain in the press corps and all
of his colleagues and the and the House
of Representatives with the astonishing
things he would do and get away with he
was he was just famous for his capacity
to drink more whiskey chase more women
get into more scandals than any other
legislator of his time he was literally
a genius at it
so when he set off in the fourth year of
the Afghan war in the middle of the of
the Reagan presidency for Pakistan as
the first American congressman or
senator to go look at what was actually
happening you have to bear in mind that
at that point no outsider had ever been
able to penetrate the CIA's inner circle
the clandestine services
no congressmen no senator had ever dared
even to to think that they could try to
suggest what the CIA should be doing how
much money they should be spending what
kind of weapons they should be using
and so as Charlie the most notorious and
famous Hellraiser and dangerous member
of Congress walked to the edge of the of
the Afghan war he had no business
whatsoever to be thinking that he would
within just a few short years managed to
have transformed the culture of the CIA
to have launched what amounts to the
largest CIA campaign in history the most
successful one of all time the most
ruthless in a good cause
but these are some of the wonders of
being a reporter to encounter stories
that that otherwise might vanish and
never be told and ask yourself a
question and try to have your mind
imagined what the person looks like who
is responsible for having funded and
sponsored the only successful jihad in
modern history
you can probably picture what he looks
like I assume you'd think he has a beard
he probably prays five times a day turns
to Mecca and you could imagine the way
he thinks about the United States at
least most people would think that way
and so it becomes really astonishing to
think that the sponsor of the greatest
jihad in modern history the force that
ended up by giving the Soviets their
Vietnam in Afghanistan was none other
than Charlie Wilson and this is really
at the heart of the story and before I
gets mad at him
you have to realize that back then of
Muslims from Afghanistan with the
freedom fighters who Ronald Reagan
brought into the White House and that we
praised across the board as as people
who embodied Liberty who were really our
surrogate soldiers in this war but this
is a story which we can't tell the whole
thing right here but enough to point out
that it is the once again the idea of
how one man can make a huge difference
and in this case Charlie who began in
little Trinity Texas with less than
3,000 population and growing up
listening on the radio to Winston
Churchill right before the Battle of
Britain tallying the English people
never to surrender and listening to all
of our great leaders and Edward Armour
oh and FDR at the right act the day of
infamy Charlie was a man who a boy who
had one of those dreams that boys have
that he would grow up one day to lead a
great battle for freedom and this was a
dream that was so big in his mind that
he didn't describe it or discuss it with
anybody because he knew he would be a
laughingstock and so he masqueraded much
of his life as a pure hedonist which is
what he was but late at night you could
find him in his bedroom
after whatever evening carousing had
taken place about 4:00 or 5:00 in the
morning reading deeply into military
history every speech the church will
ever wrote every moment that would
become perhaps a model for him in later
years and what he managed to do in the
period of the 80s in the very end of the
Cold War was to single-handedly use his
influence on the Appropriations
Committee to do something that no other
member of Congress had ever dreamed of
doing which is simply to walk right into
the middle of the CIA and tell them that
they were wrong
that he was going to put it into endless
war and containment that we're going
back to the kennedy idea of pay any
price bear any burden and if you have
people fighting for their liberty
willing to do the fighting themselves we
will get behind them and so what was a
would have been a bleeding campaign that
would have been good propaganda for the
United States and fight to the last
Afghan for the Afghans turned into a
battle that broke the back of Soviet
power the ended the mystique of the
Soviets and when the last Afghan walked
out of last Soviet walked out of
Afghanistan in February of 1989 and the
station chief wrote his cable to words
we won
just a few months later the Berlin Wall
came down and we began to see the end of
this nuclear nightmare that we'd had for
all of these years afterward and this
was really this was all because of an
amazing campaign that Charlie launched
and led and he hid in plain sight all
the way drinking carousing going to the
war front with the Mujahideen with a
beautiful former beauty queens and
hiding in plain sight always and it is a
story that could have vanished and I'll
just I'll just leave you with just
one line which is what the CIA director
after the 1993 at the end of the Soviet
empire absolutely no one had been no
parades celebrate the end of the Cold
War no person singled out for particular
valor but in a secret campaign a secret
ceremony secretive one at the Central
Intelligence Agency none other than
Charlie Wilson was brought in and the
director began by saying the defeat and
breakup of the Soviet empire is one of
the great events of world history there
were many heroes in this battle but to
Charlie Wilson must go a special
recognition and then Jim Woolsey
described compared him to lack Walesa
climbing over the fence at Gdansk to
launch the Solidarity movement and he
described how he reminded everyone how
invincible the Soviets had seemed just
so recently and how Charlie Wilson
engineered one of the lethal body blows
that had wrecked the Communist Empire
without him Woolsey concluded history
might have been hugely different
and sadly different so we'll talk about
the aftermath later but for the moment
that's that was my privilege to be able
to come across and chronicle the story
of this odd hero and the white Horace
thank you George you and I have had a
similar problem wrestled with I too have
tried to have the issue of how to
explain to the public that that Charlie
Wilson was in addition to being
everything that was publicly known about
him was one of the most shrewd
politicians ever to set foot in the
house chamber and I think your your book
when you the the highlight of of this
was how Charlie Wilson wound up on the
House Ethics Committee
this is this perhaps the story we will
hear about later now now the hero of our
tale Charlie Wilson Paul let me have
this one because I do better on my feet
it brings back all sorts of sentimental
memories to be in this particular Hall I
used to sit back over in that corner for
for six of the happiest years of my life
I'm happy that my colleague and best
friend Joe Christie and Tana are here
today I want to thank Paul burka who
always gave me the benefit of the doubt
Molly Ivins who sometimes has given me
the benefit of the doubt I would like to
recognize Lesley Dawson and a candy Shia
Hooper is two of our most celebrated
angels the their activities were
chronicled well in the book and most of
all George prowl who I never ever
thought that there was really a book
here and he and I talked about it late
into the night many nights and I never
thought it I never thought there was
enough for a book I certainly never
thought it would get written and I never
thought that in any stroke of the
imagination that it would be a but it
would be a best-seller and would be a
movie but there were many different
opinions of me when when this was going
on and I want to give you a couple of
them and then I want to tell you a
little bit about the war and then I'm
sure that Paul will sit me down for
questions once when I had been in to
Afghanistan and we had been we had
engaged the Russians the Soviet
invincible army that terrorized the
entire West and the world turned out not
to be as invincible as I thought it was
as as when they finally when they
finally became engaged
with people who were not afraid to die
and who were bent on driving them from
their land but anyway this was after one
particularly successful venture and this
is very complimentary and self-serving
and me to read this but I did many
things in this chamber that were
self-serving so I will continue when
Brigadier Youssef came to take the
congressman back to general Akhtar in
president Zia he noticed something
different about the American his men
told him of Wilson's valour and
endurance of how he impressed even the
Mujahideen Yousef who was not wild about
Americans couldn't help but be taken by
this one he was a brave man full of
energy a man who dominated the scene the
general says I had a lot of respect for
him he wanted to take revenge for
American blood spilled in Vietnam now
that was general youssef's opinion i
would like to read you a book review
written by some australian pervert but i
think you'll enjoy crowd describes
people who's ethical decrepitude was
complemented by unmitigated desire to be
regarded as influential there is hardly
a person he mentions whom you would have
in your house to polish your boots but
they have a weird fascination engendered
bothers total dedication to
self-importance the main character in
this rattling good yarn Charlie Wilson
was a US congressman when the Cold War
was raging rarely can the prefix the
Honorable have been less appropriate the
man was a drunken shiftless ignorant
lying drug taking zipper flapping
corrupt power crazed [ __ ]
his as only of his only value was his
ability through membership of
influential congressional committees to
move large sums of money legally and
often otherwise as subsidies and to
purchase weapons and equipment for
groups fighting the Soviet Army in
Afghanistan the fact that most of the
cash was wasted meant nothing to him
so as my friend Larry King advised me
when George was writing the book and
when it appeared to George was actually
going to finish the book that you can
plan on getting knocked around a little
bit but as it turned out the the the
Knox work were not that many in 1979 at
Christmas the invincible all-conquering
Red Army invaded a small country full of
illiterate tribesmen and shepherds most
of whom had never seen a toilet
we all thought at the time well this is
just another example of Soviet tyranny
these people will be enslaved as have
all the other people and of course the
great mantra of the Red Army was where
the Red Army goes it never comes back
funny thing happened six weeks passed
and the shepherds and tribesmen were
there World War one and fill rifles were
still in the mountains sniping at the
Soviets this went on for another year I
began to notice as did others that on
the streets of Kabul Russian officers
were being killed with knives and with
stones both in the darkness and in the
daylight
after a few weeks of this it began to
occur to me that these people these
people these 20 million people that they
had made the decision themselves to
fight to the very end that they had made
the decision that their lives were not
going to be sold to cheaply although
they were being sold to cheaply and that
they were going to make the Russians pay
and that the Russians were never gonna
subdue them now if the Soviets and
Russians had read history a little bit
they might have hesitated about invading
this country this comes these people
without any weapons that all had
convenient can defeated the British army
twice at the height of the power of the
British Empire they had defeated ginga's
Khan they had defeated Alexander the
Great it's a very very unhealthy country
to invade after a while I finally went
to Afghanistan in 1981 - and and met the
Mujahideen and I'll never forget the
first day Joe was with me in this big
tent and the only people that were in
there were all there were all men and
they were all between the all under
seventeen are over 65 because all the
rest were in the mountains hunting down
Soviet soldiers to kill I made a speech
that day that I was extremely moved by
their determination and their extreme
desire for revenge and and I made a
speech to them that I thought was pretty
good I told him that we were we were
looking at the squalor of the refugee
camps and I told them that that America
would come to their assistance that we
would provide medicine that we would
provide doctors that we would provide
blankets that
would provide warmer temps that we would
see that their suffering would end those
that were resisting the evil empire it
was a funny thing how they responded the
old men would stand up and through their
interpreters they said you can keep your
medicine you can keep your antibiotics
you can keep your wheat and you can keep
your tents and you can keep your
blankets all we want is something with
which to kill Russians and we want
something with which to shoot down the
Soviet helicopters
it made a profound impression on me and
I came home determined that we weren't
going to let them sell their lives quite
that cheaply there was a great cultural
class between myself and some other
members of Congress that thought the way
I did that thought that this was one
outraged two-minute for the Kremlin one
too many they were dropping bombs
disguised to look like toys so children
would pick them up and blow their hands
off and then their parents would have to
spend all of their time and energy
nursing the children who would never of
course recover but that way the fathers
couldn't go and fight fight the invaders
but we determined at that point that the
CIA was wrong because the agency's idea
was this was a marvelous chance to
embarrass the Soviet Union it was a
marvelous chance to bleed away assets
that would be better spent by them in
East Germany threatening the West and it
would be a marvelous chance to show the
world their tyranny but they didn't have
any idea of giving them a chance to win
and that was the great test of wills and
that's what the book is all about
this was one war that was a
congressional war it was funded and
driven by the House of Representatives
and to some degree the Senate it changed
the culture of the CIA before it was
over they had changed their mind and
they had decided if we were going to
provide the means for people to fight we
had to provide the means for people to
win and the long and the short of it is
that nine years later 1989 on February
the 15th the all-powerful all-conquering
invincible Red Army ignominiously and in
disgrace marched out of Afghanistan and
lost its standing in the Kremlin lost
its ability to influence events and as a
result was unable to persuade Gorbachev
and other leaders that there was a
military option in Poland that there was
a military option in Czechoslovakia and
above all there was a military option to
the destruction of the Berlin Wall and
all the rest is history
thank you very much
thank you I'm going to ask a couple of
questions in the meantime you all can
start going to the back microphone to
ask your questions about this and would
appreciate it if you would George let's
just do a little book talk how did you
go from being a TV producer who was you
filmed over there what was the little
spark that led you to think that this is
possibly a book and how long did it take
from that spark to when you really sat
down to start doing it well it only took
about 15 years to put the book together
but in the beginning the odd part of it
is that Charlie didn't strike me as a
character for the center of a book and
but I happened to find myself in
Pakistan just at the moment when the
very first withdrawal took place at the
Soviets from the border areas and
Charlie it was in town and he invited me
I was with Harry Reasoner at that point
it was the correspondent for 60 minutes
and he invited us to accompany him in to
review the troops and so we arrived at
the border and all of a sudden that
spark you're talking about lit up
because at the border there were the
Horsemen of Genghis Khan waiting for us
all these medieval figures with great
beards and just laden with every kind of
weapon you could imagine galloping at
the front of a caravan leading us in
with just unbelievable numbers of
stingers and every weapon you could
conceive of and when we got to the fort
there were just hordes of these rather
dangerous looking characters just
delighted to see Charlie there their
commander and they were all cheering and
who painted up and we went the day was
like something out of the
you know Alibaba and there's any endless
thieves but it was here were these great
feasts rolled out and men from another
time and age and a war that was being
won and for some reason this tall Texan
was being hailed by them as if he were
their commander and I didn't quite know
what was happening but I knew something
was up and Harry Reasoner at that point
named the book he said my god this is
Charlie Wilson's War so that was the
spark right we have a questioner in the
audience and let's take that question
thank you I have a question for the
congressman congressman Wilson is it
true that you're hiding Osama bin Laden
and the Trinity River bottoms and East
Texas pretty hard I think to keep Osama
hidden over there and it'd be pretty
hard to keep him safe at all and then
finally one final quick question about
Texas political history would you
explain to the c-span audience and those
of us in the chamber here why you were
the author of the first Texas sales tax
bill in 1961 I'm glad you brought that
up I'm glad you brought that up that was
when I was a freshman as you'll recall
and it takes this legislature and some
of our leaders decided that the only way
to defeat the sales tax was for those
that were opposed to it to bring it up
for a quick vote and get it defeated I
was drafted as the author and as you
know the damn thing passed
however in my hope hopefully for our
salvation purposes sitting in that back
corner there I would like everyone to
know that I opened the filibuster which
defeated the sales tax being put on food
and therefore we have probably the least
regressive sales tax in the country but
I plead guilty to all of my misdeeds
that occurred here and other places I
would like to say that the george has
been very graphic about all of my
misbehavior and all of you probably
didn't have to read it to know it but i
would like to say that i am somewhat
reformed now and i would like that i
would like to for my wife to stand up
and for everybody to see that i'm now
properly
how did how did you feel about the fact
that when he started asking you
questions about your past when George
started that did you have a second
thought about maybe I shouldn't have
agreed to be the subject of this book
after all I certainly did I certainly
did and it turned out that like you like
other like like you and like Molly and
like like all the rest of the Chronicle
my activity George gave me the benefit
of the doubt in a lot of cases and and I
said it turned out okay well you know I
think you could even try to explain this
one but there is a law of political
physics which is that politicians tend
to want to promote the positive about
themselves and to de-emphasize the
negative and one of the things that
Charlie did when he cooperated with me
was always mystifying which is that he
constantly was talking about the the
unfortunate things and with great
graphic detail and in the end this was
an exercise in code-breaking for me I
had to constantly break behind the
compulsion to present himself as the
sinner that he is into the bedrock areas
and then he would come finally
encouraged and give a good run but it
was never easy that way
odd well and the other thing the great
mystery was that how East Texas could
which is supposed to be a moralistic
part of the state how they could
tolerate this were they living
vicariously perhaps oh yes yes I think
that people tend to underrate the
judgment of rural people in Texas and
perhaps rural southerners in general but
for 32 years 24 36 years
for 36 years the people in East Texas
elected me every two years knowing all
of the sins that took place but I think
that Georgia said that I was the
designated Center and that they got some
vicarious pleasure out of it but I think
mostly politicians can survive a whole
lot if they're not hypocritical about it
well you know there are reminds me
briefly of a story we'll take another
question but I was Charlie was a great
source when I was covering but I would
cover Congress for Texas Monthly and one
time I asked him out one of his
Democratic colleagues who the story was
had been at the center of this political
battle and Charlie I asked Charlie about
it and he said oh he's always the hero
of his own tales I said Charlie what
about you and he said well I don't
expect you to believe it and let's take
another question yes my questions for
congressman Wilson and it's commenting a
question I agree we won the war the
covert war there but we seem to have
squandered the aftermath I wondered what
your impressions are of why didn't we
back the northern alliance why did we
kind of drop back and hand the ball off
to the Pakistani intelligence services
and then they in turn back the Taliban
and it just doesn't make sense to me we
seem to switched horses in the middle of
a race just say why did we back the
Northern Alliance in the aftermath why
did we back out of there so fast it
seems like we cut and run before it got
settled and we allowed the Pakistanis to
take over the running of Afghanistan
there's no question about it you're a
hundred percent right if I understand
the question right but George and I were
bragging about what happened up until
February the 15th 1989 and the truth is
that after the Soviets had ignominiously
with their tails between their legs
snuck out of Afghanistan the United
States simply disengaged and we had left
a completely destroyed country
a country with 3 million refugees in
Pakistan a country that had no
electricity whose grazing fields were
were all had 10 million mines in them
and there was just really not much hope
without a very strong effort made on
behalf of America on behalf of the
people that did this wonderful thing for
the West we might add that that the that
the Russian army fest up to 28,000
fatalities it was probably double that
these people who could not read or write
who who are late who who were thought to
be untrainable in modern weapons and all
of those things through sheer sacrifice
through sheer willingness to die and to
have them to be dismembered they did it
and we were the beneficiaries of it and
we didn't even hang around to say thank
you and that's one of the great
disgraces of all Americas parts and
that's all I can say George do you know
it's it's a critical question because
given the concerns that most people have
it's easy to throw the baby out with the
bathwater and and say that this was a
mistake because of what happened
afterward I don't think you can take
away from the contribution it made to
the end of the Cold War it was a
historic event but afterward most
everything the United States government
did was a disaster just and it created
unnecessarily the problems that we
encountered today do you know the
Afghans have never and the Afghans
themselves have never been engaged in
what any of us would call terrorist
activities outside of their countries
anybody that comes in as an invader
you know God saved them but outside they
don't do with the Arabs do and others
have but at the very end of the Afghan
war
maybe as many as 30,000 volunteers Arab
volunteers came in from around the world
they were not influential in the outcome
of the war they didn't determine that
that was all an Afghan event but they
certainly became ideologically engaged
they started to network together lots of
them were some of them had good causes
lots of them had were really rabid you
know including that bin Laden factions
and afterward instead of us going in and
even trying to bring that country back
to where it was when the Russians
invaded very primitive we cut and ran
and we left a a devastated landscape in
which the only people with any
purchasing power were the Arabs had been
Laden types and they they got Running
Room there which shouldn't have been
there isn't worse they walked away with
the capacity because we never
acknowledged what we had done as
partners with the Afghans they were able
to believe or make people believe that
it was them with Allah alone that was
responsible for defeating a modern super
power and it has fed a notion that's
irrational and dangerous for everybody
concerned that it is the Islamic moment
and that having knocked off one
superpower you can do another and we
needed to event we need to now lead
something positive behind so it doesn't
look as if we only could engage them to
kill Russians and afterward no
responsibility question congressman of
the Arab Baskins that George refers to
after the war went out back to their
home countries went to Chechnya Bosnia
Algeria where a hundred thousand people
died and all over the Middle East they
created turmoil and the Arab Afghans the
Mujahideen who were drawn into this
largely because we helped to empower
them and give them the sense that they
could defeat this you know this great
Empire did you have the sense when you
were talking to these people that you
talked so you had
fired so much that you were empowering a
kind of religious fanaticism that would
come back and strike it to West was that
ever a feature of your conversations
with these people no it was the the idea
was to defeat the Red Army the idea was
to to destroy the evil empire the idea
was to not wake up in the morning
wondering if the Soviet if the
invincible Red Army had invaded West
Germany as a result of what they did
what we did to help them the in my
judgment all of Eastern Europe was freed
a million Jews were free to leave Russia
and go to Israel all of those things and
it was only through our neglect that the
blowback that you're talking about
really occurred but there's only and and
much of it's true because there was a
vacuum there that bin Laden could go to
and organize al Qaeda and use against
the West I think that that could have
occurred in several other places I think
it could have occurred in Burma I think
it could have occurred and Yemen I think
could have occurred a several other
places but the fact is that it did occur
in Afghanistan and it did occur because
we walked away from a job that was not
finished I would like to point out one
thing that that George thinks I'm overly
defensive what I do this but people
think of the Afghans because of the
Taliban they think of the Afghans as
worldwide terrorists in the bombings of
our embassies in East Africa and the two
efforts made the last being each
successful of course to destroy the
World Trade Center in the attack on the
USS Cole all of those we have a list of
45 terrorists that we think participated
in those in those activities some of
them have been arrested some of them
were killed in 9/11 but some of them are
still at large but not a one of them not
a one of them
was an Afghan and not a one of them was
a non-arab they weren't any Turks or
Iranians they were all Saudis Egyptians
and so I don't think we should get him
confused but you're right
in that an atmosphere was created and a
vacuum was left that the radical Arabs
filled and really if your concerns are
are valid in that if the United States
is going to act as an empire and
completely reconfigure the power
realities of a region having done that
if it does not intervene to create a
positive energy and option then you've
just you've just opened the doors for
chaos and for unintended consequences
and so we really are just guilty as
could be of irresponsibility after after
having performed something which was
miraculous a secret war that had 10
years maybe six billion dollars not one
congressman a senator ever standing up
to oppose it something that operated
within our value systems and then the
moment had ended for some pathetic
reason we just turned and did everything
disastrously it was a philosophical
objection to nation-building at the time
or was it just no one made a decision it
was there an effort made to try it
I think after 9/11 I asked you about
this and I thought your answer was it
was just hard to find out which faction
was to support well that was true but if
the United States had gone and stayed
and been patient it's been three or four
billion dollars we could have we could
have worn it down I'm sure there were
different factions in Japan and Germany
in 1945 but it took it took a certain
amount of patience but most of all most
of all we just left when we were but and
president the first president Bush was
president at the time and our member of
speech he made
after the Berlin Wall came down and
after Czechoslovakia had the Velvet
Revolution and after the poles were free
you know and he used the term there's
probably Peggy Noonan's term but he used
the term changes of biblical proportion
which I truly believe occurred and it
was a humongous distraction for the
United States and here one or two of us
were kind of pickin away trying to get a
couple of billion dollars more on top of
the other five or six billion that we'd
spent and just nobody wanted to listen
to us
nobody wanted to pay attention because
of the spectacular things that were
occurring worldwide of biblical
proportions
and we pay a price for that hope we were
doing much better in Afghanistan this
time in my view and we still are they're
still roads being built there's
electrical wire being strung there there
is a life in the cities but the with
without pronouncing one way or the other
about the Iraqi war but it's been a
terrible distraction from what we were
doing in Afghanistan you know the
problem we had is that it was a secret
war and it really deserved to have
broken that secrecy the Cold War had
ended and Soviets had collapse if we had
acknowledged that this was a triumph
that we shared with the Afghans that it
was a battle that we were proud of it
would have then hopefully have allowed
us to have felt some accountability and
responsibility to to the Afghans but as
it stood there was no constituency for
it so Charlie who had managed to operate
because of the consensus around an anti
Soviet presence was suddenly without the
capacity without the leverage really to
lobby very strongly for doing the right
thing and I he tried a little bit but as
he said he's pretty good at not pursuing
lost causes and he he jumped out and
it's too bad
next question hi Charlie
I'm a former constituent of yours but
more importantly my grandmother was a
former constituent of yours and just for
the people who are here today that don't
know you I think that's a very important
lesson that you were always honest and
forthcoming with the homefolks
and the seniors were a large
constituency of viewers back home and
that you always took care of them and I
know you're going home on Monday back to
die ball Texas and I just wanted to know
what is your key message going to be for
those constituents when you go home on
Monday just go tell them I still love
them are you ready for another question
I just wanted to know if you were
president today what would you be doing
as far as American foreign policy goes
what would you be doing differently
especially it also as far as conduct of
the intelligence agencies given what you
learned throughout this entire
experience and what do we as voters need
to know as we look forward to make
choices about the president for next
year in the direction of our country
I'm a former congressional aide I never
paid any attention to international
affairs before I thought that was also
foolish waste of time I've woken up now
I'm paying a lot of attention I'm
reading but what do we need to know to
be informed voters as we go back and
look in 2004 because this is going to be
a watershed year this to make this
election makes a difference what do we
need to know that's pretty broad
question and one sentence I would and I
don't want to get into this because
we're here to talk about the book at
about the Afghan war from 1979 to 1989
and the defeat of the red army but the
short answer to your question would be I
would make sure that I didn't vote for
anybody who was going to start any
optional Wars
George is a journalist to you do you see
in the parallel lessons between between
then and now well the main thing I I
would urge everyone to do is to be wary
of the impulsive Americans to find some
group of people to demonize and demonize
it's the Japanese during World War two
we did a good job of the Communists and
and we just have to be very careful
about remembering that we are we are the
world you know everybody has a place
here and that in the case of of Islam
and even militant Islam that we have a
history this was a remarkable Alliance
that that existed during this stretch of
time and there's just no reason for us
to enter into a place where our minds
grow grow small and closed and and
paranoid we need to we need to recapture
what we're all about
another question yes first I just wanted
to say congressman I always thought it
was the Domino tournaments that kept you
in office but yeah I have a quick
question for George and then one for
Charlie
as a writer I kept wondering how much
you had to tiptoe around identities with
the CIA because I could be wrong but I
assume there must have been some
delicacies there and then congressman
how much do we need to worry about the
billions of weapons that are still out
there and in the hands of the followers
of Allah who hate this George first this
was a quite unusual book well as far as
writing about the CIA because I was able
to talk to most most everyone who was
really critically involved and it didn't
just have one view it included people
within the CIA who had terrible
arguments with each other really thought
that they were you know some who thought
Charlie was the greatest menace to the
Republic others who thought that he was
the salvation and there were there were
of course some people who whose
identities I learned about but who are
active who you know he there's no
earthly reason to put their names in but
for people who have retired they're you
know they're their names are included
and I was able to get the great deal of
cooperation and it's probably largely
because there were only two people who
actually knew what had happened
oddly the CIA itself didn't know what
had happened it was Charlie and his
co-conspirator this marvelous unusual
fellow named Gustav Ricardo's and the
two of them gave me a pretty good inside
look at how it had all unfolded and
armed with knowledge you can then get to
other people and then pretty soon with a
campaign that stretched over ten years
and their policy of segmenting
information vulcanizing it so a person
who to the station chief in a two year
period doesn't know what happens in the
next two-year period and before long you
kind of possess the the book on on what
had happened the problem of all of the
weapons that are in Afghanistan many of
which we sent there really has not
turned out to be a problem because the
significant weapons that are used to for
instance against American soldiers today
in Iraq and are used in terrorist
attacks all over the world the basic
weapons are a K forty seventh of which
there are millions in the world and
which are made in China and Egypt and
Syria Israel just made all over the
Middle East as well as in the West and
they're readily available
Sam sevens which is the which apparently
shut down the Chinook with the sixteen
fatalities we shot down with the Sam
seven Sam sevens we they were readily
available to the CIA in 1980 and 81 and
we used them against the Soviet
helicopters but not too much use because
we were fighting gunships which have a
great many
diversionary tools such as flares and
chaff on board the only weapon that we
all worried about and we still worried
about was a stinger and it was the
absolute Silver Bullet in the war it was
what really and truly defeated the red
army because of what it did for the
morale of the Mujahideen to have
something to shoot back at these savages
that were mowing down women and children
and their villages and that heretofore
they had been invited shoot back I might
say that once the stingers had been
there for a couple of weeks
the swaggering Soviet hind helicopter
pilots who heretofore had been the
invoke Superman
of the Soviet forces suddenly became the
the the Soviet infantry who had depended
on them began instead of referring to
them as their heroes they began
referring to them as cosmonauts because
they wouldn't come down where the
bullets were flying are the stingers
were flying but and George has not had a
little disagreement about this last
night but within Afghanistan there were
probably left a couple of hundred maybe
300 stingers we did everything in the
world to get him back we got a lot of
them back but there still probably two
or three hundred but we never there's
never been one fired at a at an airliner
as far as we know there's never been one
fired and the general conventional
thinking is that that that they are
unable to replace the batteries so as
far as rpg-7 switch shot down the
helicopter a couple of days ago and
which shut down our helicopters in
Mogadishu
the RPG sevens are available worldwide
on any markets bizarre as well as
mortars and ak-47s and those things the
Stinger was the only sophisticated
weapon and thank God we haven't seen one
of those but there they were the case of
a great deal of worry there is one other
problem though which is that Afghans are
like Hatfields and McCoys after the
invader is defeated that they
temporarily unite historically and then
when they the enemy leaves they all set
at each other again only this time they
said at each other with hundreds of
millions of dollars worth of weapons
from both the Russians and the Americans
and that makes the effort of
nation-building and trying to work
things out in Afghanistan wildly
difficult we have come to the end of our
program I want to thank both of you
George cryo Charlie Wilson thank you for
coming
yes